okay today I'm going to talk to you
about atom economy now atom economy is a
really important thing to consider
whenever we're considering a chemical
process to make a particular product so
I think it's easiest if I just dive
straight in and I show you an example
so in this example we're reacting sodium
oxide with a hydrochloric acid in order
to produce sodium chloride and water so
let's say in this reaction I'm trying to
make sodium chloride now in most
chemical reactions you don't just get
one product you'd normally get a few
different products at least a couple of
different products so in this case
sodium chloride is what we try to make
but water is our by-product is our waste
product so what acts of economy kind of
shows us is what is the percentage of
the mass of reactants which is converted
into our desired product because the
higher the act of economy the better
news for us and we'll see why that is a
little bit later so the first thing that
we need to do whenever we're dealing
with an atom economy equation is first
of all we need to establish what our
desired product is which is this here so
in this particular experiment we're
trying to make sodium chloride so we
need to figure out what percentage of
this overall product is mass is sodium
chloride so what we need to do next is
we need to get a periodic table and we
need to find out the relative formula
mass of this and of our h2o so first of
all sodium is just here which is 23 so
sodium is I've got two lots of 23 and
then I'm going to add it to my chlorine
which is here so 35 point five but again
there's two lots of that so it's times
two times thirty five point five now
this is going to tell me my the mass
relative formula mass of my sodium
chloride
so it's 117 now here I've got h2o so
H is just here so I've got 2 times 1
plus oxygen which is here 16 so don't
you calculate for that that's the answer
though 18 so what I've done is I found
the the mass of my sodium chloride and
the mass of my so we ready to forming a
mass of my water what I now need to do
is I need to find the total mass of all
of the products so to do that it's nice
and simple all I do is 117 plus 18 which
gives me a value of a hundred and
thirty-five so the the relative forming
the mass of all of my products is 135
now what I'm interested in
if I might add some economy is what
percentage of all of these products is
my desired product so my desired product
is sodium chloride and here is the
relative formulas for that 117 here is
the mass of all of my products so what I
need to do is I need to do 117 out of
135 because this is the proportion of my
products which is useful and to express
it as a percentage all I'm gonna do is
multiply my answer by a hundred so let's
quickly do that 107 oops it is a hundred
and seventeen out of a hundred and
thirty-five multiplied by a hundred so
my answer to this is eighty six point
six seven percent so that's how active
economy works obviously the higher the
percentage the better because then we've
got less wasted products so let's have a
look at one more example and here's an
example right here let's imagine we're
trying to make magnesium oxide by
reacting magnesium with oxygen now just
by looking at this because there's only
one product I could instantly say see
there's no waste products at all
so therefore might add some economy in
this instance must be a hundred percent
now a hundred percent at some economy is
really really good news and the reason
why it's good
there's no waste no waste at all so
there's two really important reasons why
it's good not to have waste first of all
we have no waste we have a higher profit
all of our all of our raw materials have
been converted into our our product and
so we're not wasting any money it's
really really it's really really
economic secondly it's better for the
environment so if we think about
environmental issues we're not producing
any harmful waste products so that's
also something to consider when we're
considering at some economy so just to
summarize with just a recap at some
economy is all about what percentage of
our products are this way what
percentage of the mass of our total
products are comprised of our desired
product thank you very much